a visit to lugan almost always begins on
the mainland in the city of schnoz owned
the old town with its imposing gothic
architecture is listed as a unesco world
heritage site the shillelagh sound
separates the German mainland from
glucan which is accessible via bridge or
by ferry the chalk cliffs in the north
are the islands most famous landmark
they were immortalized by the German
Romantic painter cuspid Ovid fleetly
some 70,000 people live on the island
but they're joined by some six million
visitors every year I'm from Switzerland
and he wanted to show me the island the
water it's great the Baltic is a magical
attraction for Mike's islands there's
always plenty going on in the southeast
of the island
you can shop or simply take in the charm
of the spa architecture in the north you
can enjoy tranquility in unspoiled
nature
and one of the best places for getting a
good view of the whole island is the
gannets hunting lodge which was built in
the 19th century it's quite a walk-up
but worth it in the end
and if you're looking for more exercise
Logan is also ideal for watersports
kitesurfing is particularly popular in
the shallow waters of the Osmond button